pour marie jeanne à l'hymne est clos et
la cuisine c'est une affaire de famille
c'est guyancourt toise incarne trois
générations ensemble elles se sont
inscrits à l'atelier de cuisine malgache
à la maison de quartier théodore monod
la grand mère la mère et la petite fille
est ce qui vous a motivé le partage et
de partager et couvriront fournir à
l'armée fait de même
le but c'est mon père qui que les nems à
la maison donc eh oui les
incontournables n'est mal à crêpes de
blé garnis de viande fraîche et de
légumes
également au programme du cours de
cuisine les traditionnels sans bosses
plus connu en france sous le nom de
samoussas alors laissons bien
généralement le fait quand on reçoit du
monde on le met en
en apéritif la force et les facile à
faire mais c'est le pillage qui prend du
temps voilà c'est à dire faire le
triangle
il faut un petit coup de main ouais
c'est le manipuler la l'impact parce que
ce serait très vite autres mais
caractéristique de madagascar le achard
une salade de légumes à déguster avec le
riz quotidien se compose de carottes de
chou de haricots verts
sans oublier les poivrons et la
vinaigrette et lisette fait partie de
l'association espoir foi et amour qui
propose régulièrement des activités
autour de la culture malgache
d'autres ateliers culinaires seront
mises en place à la maison de quartier
théodore monod pour promouvoir les
cultures du monde
et comme on dit en malgache masse
tucuman